bonsoir nous sommes le 11 juin 2015
l'heure du journal de la rédaction sur
tv fil 78 voici les principaux titres
que nous allons à développer aujourd'hui
hommage je m'attends verrière à
versailles victimes de mohamed merah en
2012 un square à son nom a été inauguré
lui qui avait grandi dans cette ville
les différentes antennes du laboratoire
national d'essai en grève à travers la
france mobilisation également à
l'antenne de trappes les salariés
parlent d'une gestion calamiteuse de
leur structure ils craignent pour leur
avenir
11e édition du forum santé dès demain
saint quentin en yvelines plus d'une
vingtaine de partenaires santé services
et associations spécialisées en santé
public présent au centre commercial à
montigny-le-bretonneux
la ville de versailles a donc inauguré
hier un square au nom de jonathan semble
leur ce professeur d'origine juive a été
assassiné par mohamed merah à toulouse
en 2012 jonathan sengler était très
attaché à cette commune yvelinoise il a
fréquenté versailles pendant son enfance
il s'était également marié à la
synagogue à la commune qui a donc voulu
lui rendre un hommage michael et demi
d'euros et william l
un square pour ne pas oublier un jardin
public au nom de jonathan sandler a été
inauguré ce mercredi le professeur
d'origine juive est l'une des victimes
de la tuerie de mohamed merah il a été
abattu devant l'école ozar hatorah de
toulouse avec ses deux fils arie et
gabriel le 19 mars 2012
la commune de versailles tenait à leur
rendre hommage je suis très sensible à
la mémoire comme je les dis on se
souvient toujours de nom de l'assassin
jamais des victimes
et là au moins en plus ceux ci dans un
bus scolaire
mon fils voulait c'était sa vocation
d'enseigner donc en plus à versailles
c'est une ville qu'il aimait donc il a
été scout à versailles il a été l'élève
de marcel tassencourt donc
c'est pas mieux on est en souffrance
c'est pas facile pour monsieur cents de
l'heure pour safari il a perdu un fils
de petits enfants moi j'ai perdu un fils
ça c'est dur c'est dur mais il faut
rester debout il faut passer ce message
de paix le vivre ensemble le respect de
l'autre c'est important des
personnalités du monde religieux et
politiques étaient présents le ministre
de l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve était
en déplacement dans le cadre de la
journée nationale d'hommage aux victimes
doit être là pour dire qu'on n'oublie
pas le martyre de ceux qui sont tombés
sous le feu de barbe à dire aussi que la
république est plus forte que certaines
rappeler ce que sont les valeurs de la
république a rappelé l'attachement qui
est le nôtre à faire en sorte que
l'antisémitisme n'est aucune place dans
la société française parce que
l'antisémitisme c'est le contraire de la
république
on a mis là une pierre sur la mémoire
collective la mémoire nationale et ça me
semble très important dans un lieu des
enfants enjouée le monde entier
villetelle mu ne tient que par le sou
des enfants qui étudient ici ce sera le
souffre et les rires des enfants qui
rient qui joue qui redonnera vie à
jonathan sengler et samedi à gabriel
sengler aimé ramond son époux
au total c'est une centaine de personnes
qui a assisté à cette inauguration du
square jonathan semble les employés
duels et ne étaient en grève ce matin le
laboratoire national d'essais une grève
nationale dans les sept antennes de
l'hexagone les employés qui dénonce une
mauvaise gestion de l'organisme qui les
a conduit à supprimer des postes
elle est allée à leur rencontre sur le
site de trappes ils étaient 150 ce matin
réunis devant le portail de l'organisme
elle est de deux trappes une grève d'une
matinée pour soutenir leurs collègues
dont les postes sont menacés
aujourd'hui il est prévu un transfert
d'activité de toulouse / trappe et
poitiers donc avec
inévitablement une fermeture de
l'antenne et une externalisation d
emploi de logistique et maintenant sein
du site de paris sur toulouse ce sont
sept postes devraient disparaître et
quatre sur paris en cause la mauvaise
gestion de l'organisme par la direction
on est un établissement public donc on a
des comptes à équilibrer et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les en matière on veut
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé en termes de
profitabilité de nos affaires qui
aujourd'hui ne sont plus haut niveau et
donc en effet la situation se dégrade
interpeller la direction et le public
pour sauver leur emploi c'était
l'objectif ce matin de cette grève les
employés ont ensuite repris le travail
en début d'après midi la maison de
l'emploi et des entreprises à plaisir
est en travaux depuis le mois d'octobre
dernier elle vient de rouvrir ses portes
dans des locaux flambant neufs la visite
guidée c'est avec catherine gélato
marianne dominiak et conseillère
d'insertion professionnelle à la mission
locale de plaisir elle vient d'intégrer
ces nouveaux locaux sont très aéré sont
très agréables moi j'aime beaucoup la
couleur la mission locale accueille
environ 900 jeunes parents tous âgés de
16 à 25 ans le but les aider dans leur
recherche d'emploi sont des jeunes qui
ont quitté le système scolaire en
majorité et qui ont besoin justement
d'une aide pour se redéfinir un nouveau
projet et
et de manière à les insérer le mieux
possible dans la vie professionnelle
donc on va travailler sur un projet qui
peuvent de la formation de la recherche
d'emploi mettre en place des ateliers à
la maison de l'emploi et de l'entreprise
on ne trouve pas que la mission locale
il y a également l'antenne de pôle
emploi qui a doublé sa surface d'accueil
et le service développement économique
de la ville le plaisir le service de
développement économique c'est un
service qui travaille en lien avec les
entreprises et qui aujourd'hui est
plutôt dans une écoute renforcée puisque
nous souhaitons depuis pas mal de temps
je veux dire de bonne année en tout cas
avoir un contact beaucoup plus direct
avec les entreprises on a encore des
zones à développer sa des gâtines qui
mérite aussi un bon coup de
rafraîchissante
il ya aussi la zone de ste apolline qui
sait l'asf en développant plus tôt je
dirais quand on va rentrer au nez au
sein de l'acas qui à partir du 1er
janvier le taux de chômage de la ville
de plaisir s'établit aux alentours de 7%
ses trois points de moins qu'au plan
national les invités d'aujourd'hui est
venu parler du nouveau forum santé
bien-être de saint quentin en yvelines
qui va se dérouler demain samedi
également bonsoir marinaro les soins et
conseillère communautaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué à la
santé ou au handicap et aux personnes
âgées et catherine chauloux recevoir
responsable adjointe de l'institut de
promotion de la santé plus d'une
vingtaine de partenaires santé services
association spécialisée en santé
publique qui vont se réunir au centre
commercial espace saint quentin sur
montigny le bretonneux quel est
l'objectif dans les grandes lignes de ce
rendez vous sensibiliser un petit peu
aux problèmes du quotidien et santé oui
complètement et puis à faire découvrir
les associations locales qui apporte des
réponses en termes de santé gratuitement
sur le territoire parce que cette
association qui sont pas forcément très
connu en tout cas méconnu les gens n'ont
pas le réflexe et là on va toucher un
public plus large peut-être ben c'est ce
qu'on a pu constater depuis plus dix ans
qu'on le met en place effectivement les
personnes viennent au forum et ensuite
reviennent voir les associations au sein
de soi de lits ps soit au sein des
associations quand elles sont en dehors
de notre équipement
ça fait une dizaine d'années que le
rendez vous était lancé le bilan est
positif à chaque fois le bilan est
positif à chaque fois effectivement
l'année dernière on a fêté les 10 ans du
forum 2400 visite pour les diffuse pour
les 10 ans on a sauté retravailler le
format de ce forum on est passé de 4
jours à deux jours pour mettre en place
aussi un forum à destin
mais sion des communes les plus
éloignées ce sera se serait attendu par
tous donc ça reste sur l'espace 50 ans
le forum de deux jours reste sur
l'espace lointain mais on va mettre en
place une journée forum sur d'autres
communes cette année ce sera manille et
une autre journée sur une en cours
puisque on a constaté que la proximité
avait un réel jeu dans le cadre de ces
forums l'idée c'est de donner des
conseils bien-être prévention dépistage
animations familiales l'exposition peut
peut-être jeter un petit coup d'oeil
quand même au programme
il ya une nouveauté aussi cette année
c'est l'animation sportive à la gare de
saint quentin
alors effectivement vendredi matin à
10h30 ce sera du tai-chi donc une
animation intergénérationnelle et donc
c'est des séances enfin sur une heure de
bain d'un sport proche du des arts
martiaux
et puis samedi après midi c'est que je
me trompe pas le peuple
la zumba et les pilates donc le pilates
excusez moi donc assez un sport assez
complet et donc on espère attirer du
monde sur ces animations gratuites
il ya même du coaching en image aussi
alors le coating en images effectivement
ça sera au sein des des animations dans
le centre commercial espace saint
quentin
donc l'idée c'est un conseil une minute
dans l'idée de valoriser les personnes
et d'oser être beau la logique la
logique de tout ça c'est de parler et de
santé et de bien-être c'est
indissociable les deux puisque l'on
parle coaching en images on pense pas
forcément la santé et pourtant ça n'a
pas si je pense que aujourd'hui la la
ligne politique enfin que moi j'essaye
de le développer c'est de dire que
vraiment il ya bien sûr la santé c'est
très important dès que l'on parle de
santé on sait qu'il ya un côté très bon
on a un côté médical c'est médical la
santé c'est médical non pas forcément
et donc effectivement notre objectif
c'est de dire que la santé c'est aussi
du bien-être mais le bien-être ça vient
de quoi ça vient d'environnement ça
vient de l'aménagement ça vient du
bâtiment où on habite
de la façon dont on travaille etc dont
on ressent la façon dont on peut vivre
au quotidien et donc je pense que tout
ça ce sont des facteurs qui peuvent
influencer
disons une santé plus plus sereine
voilà donc c'est vraiment cet objectif
de se dire que la santé ce n'est pas
seulement aller chez le médecin faire
ces vaccinations et créera bien entendu
ça il faut continuer il n'est pas
question de remettre en question tout ce
qui a été lui en génère images parlaient
visite chez le médecin quand on est
malade voilà voilà c'est ça mais en
revanche c'est vrai que l'on travaille
beaucoup sur environnement et santé et
ça ça me paraît aujourd'hui très
important rien que le fait de la
pollution c'est quelque chose
d'important donc c'est de pouvoir
développer disons d'autres d'autre moyen
de se préserver
disons plutôt que de dire je suis malade
je me soigne n'ont pour le moment je
suis plutôt en bonne santé
j'essaye d'y rester donc je trouve des
solutions des situations et se sentir
bien dans sa peau de savoir se valoriser
c'est aussi peut-être donner un petit
coup de pouce à la santé on est dans la
prévention plus c'est la logique que
vous développez avec lee ps aussi
institut de promotion de la santé
oui alors qu'on pète on est dans la
prévention et pied également dans ce que
vous disiez dans la transversalité
l'intersecteur réalité l'idée c'est
qu'on peut faire de la santé en partant
du sanitaire mais on peut faire de la
santé également en partant d'autres
compétences et on souhaite également
valoriser tout ce qui peut apporter du
bien-être en passant également par les
médecines peut-être un peu plus
alternatifs tels qu'on va retrouver des
présentations au sein du forum
alors je reviens je me retourne vers
vous je reviens sur la politique qui est
menée par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
on a une illustration concrète avec le
forum qui sera mis en place est ce qu il
yad autres illustrations qu'on peut
donner dans ce cadre-là de la politique
qui est impulsée depuis maintenant un
peu plus d'un an un peu plus d'un an oui
ça fait presque un an maintenant
effectivement je pense que la politique
que l'on souhaite développer c'est
vraiment une politique participative
c'est à dire que effectivement
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus faim
plus personne ne peut travailler seul on
a besoin de cette transversalité de la
mutualisation des compétences des uns et
des autres pour pouvoir justement
accompagner les publics qui sont
peut-être
les plus fragiles et pour lequel
effectivement nous avions signé il ya
quelques années le contrat local de
santé qui se place dans le cadre de la
politique de la ville donc enfin
j'essaye de dire que la santé elle n'est
pas toute seule la santé elle fait
partie de toutes les actions et lorsque
l'on parle d'un aménagement d'un
quartier ou autre eh bien on essaye nous
de nous impliquer dans ce set mise en
place de ceux de cet aménagement pour
pouvant justement répondre 10 on a un
côté je dire plutôt bien être là et donc
santé aussi mais en terme de budget
faire de la prévention même si c'est un
coup ça permet aussi de faire des
économies par la suite voilà la logique
est développé par la cpmc dernières
années voilà c'est vraiment on travaille
aussi d'ailleurs avec avec la cpam on
travaille avec beaucoup de partenaires
et effectivement la logique ces dix ans
de faire de la prévention pour éviter
d'être obligés d'avoir recours disons
soit vraiment aux sanitaires complets
effectivement je peux on peut espérer
que ça peut faire quelques économies que
l'on cherche quand même un petit peu
actuellement on va faire une petite
pause avec un m micro-trottoir pardon
notre question du jour quels sont vos
conseils bien être santé
micro trottoir à suivre sa du sport au
moins deux fois par jour c'est ce que je
fais moi et puis au niveau nourriture
faire attention à ce qu'on mange quoi tu
sors doit faire attention au sucre je
crois que c'est le plus important est la
priorité d'abord c'est prendre beaucoup
d'eau pour avoir plus d'énergie qu'ils
puissent circuler dans le corps et
manger plus de tricks simple pas trop de
la viande avec des chaires mange un peu
de légumes avoir une activité sportive
manger équilibré sans savoir prendre du
repos trouver des activités de détente
car d'une activité physique pas que
hâter rituel un équilibre dans la vie
manger sainement c'est possible patras
très sèche ça fumait pas vexer et de
profiter de la vie en face de la ville
malgré tout malgré tout il aurait pu
ajouter ce fait les spectateurs saint
quentinois
en tout cas la prévention c'est quelque
chose qui devient
assimiler aujourd'hui par les gens on
sait qu'il faut prendre soin con quand
on voit bien vous voir par exemple aller
ps aussi on y vient pour prendre des
conseils
oui on y vient pour prendre des conseils
j'aime beaucoup ces micro trottoir parce
que les personnes ont déjà d amorce de
réponse
et ça ça nous fait vraiment plaisir ça
montre aussi qu'on peut avoir
on peut avoir cette compétence là d'être
sur le chemin de la santé du bien-être
après on vient voir les associations
pour avoir des informations plus plus
professionnel on va dire alors
effectivement quand on vient nous voir
ali ps on vient nous voir pour me
demander des conseils santé mais le plus
régulièrement c'est pour des conseils
d'orientation
donc on a un peu près huit mille visites
par an à l'accueil de lits ps et la
plupart de ces visites sont pour notre
coeur de métier qui est l'orientation
vers les structures de santé du
territoire
et puis durant ce forum santé donc santé
et bien-être qui sera proposé durant
deux jours demain après demain sur
l'espace saint quentin à montigny le
bretonneux
juste un mot vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure sur manille et l'encours aussi
l'intérieur il y aura des antennes
comment ça doit se dérouler sur ces
communes alors l'idée en fait c'est de
travailler en pilonnant co pilotage avec
chacune des communes donc l oms où elles
ont fait le choix des thématiques
qu'elle souhaitait des dates qu'elle
souhaitait et pour manier les armes où
ça va être le ca va etre instants qui va
être tenu dans le cadre de la
manifestation remets tes tongs le 8
juillet et y aura enfin le 8 juillet
pour la participation de lits ps et il y
aura d'autres d'autres jours autour de
la santé et pour elancourt ce sera à
l'automne dans le cadre de la fête de
l'automne justin l'idée c'est d'être
allé aussi tout au moins pas de rester
juste malade sur deux jours sur nous
alors c'est vrai qu'on a on a beaucoup
de chance de pouvoir être sur un lieu
aussi fédérateur que le centre
commercial
mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai que on a
posé la question aux villes en disant
est ce que vous souhaiteriez vous aussi
qu'on puisse disons on va dire entre
guillemets de délocaliser mais peut-être
un petit peu fort mais de pouvoir
effectivement vous aussi et donc là nous
sommes vraiment dans un partenariat et
un accompagnement des villes nous les
accompagnons sur leurs choix et nous
leur proposons éventuellement des
solutions c'est la façon
vous allez travailler oui la suite
vraiment c'est de ce mandat j'ai envie
de vous poser la question oui c'est
vraiment beau père c'est vraiment le
travail avec les communes parce que les
communes sont au plus près des habitants
c'est elle qui connaissent les besoins
de chacun de leurs populations en
fonction bien de la démographie on a des
villes qui évolue va je citerai pas de
ville parce que je reste tout à fait
saint-quentinoise là mais il ya des
villes où pendant un certain temps
c'était très jeunes maintenant ça
commence à vieillir donc il ya besoin
d'un accompagnement qui va être
différent et je pense que chaque commune
nous apporte aussi ses compétences et
ses connaissances du terrain et nous
nous ne rapportons les connaissances que
peut avoir les personnels de deux lits
ps et pour rencontrer les différentes
associations ce sera donc à l'espace 1
comptant pour le 11e forum santé a dès
demain merci à toutes et d'être passé
sur ce plateau
la suite de ce journal en éducation hier
dans les locaux de l'inria de versailles
la remise des prix des olympiades
académiques de mathématiques 2015 une
quarantaine de collégiens de lycéens
également récompensés pour leurs
performances sephora nomani si certaines
le sport ou le cinéma
d'autres préfèrent les maths c'est le
cas de nos lauréats aux olympiades
académiques de mathématiques
près de dix mille élèves 329 lycées et
collèges de l'académie de versailles
participer aux concours parce que j'aime
bien les mathématiques
un moyen de
enfer et
que à l'école des fois c'est facile donc
hier c'est le dur
comme ça je peux m'entraîner ont le
plaisir et surtout en fait faire des
maths en 3d par pur plaisir parce qu'on
aime les maîtres nous
on adore ça et on en fait quand on
s'ennuie quoi il y en a qui jouent aux
jeux vidéo ont fait des matières et des
ipod
les calculatrices scientifiques dernier
cri ou encore des puzzle en 3d ont
récompensé les lauréats des épreuves
composé d'algèbre et de géométrie des
gains séduisant pour encourager aux
mathématiques qui moins plébiscité
qu'avant n'en sont pas moins utile
les mathématiques sont partout on en a
besoin vraiment partout encore plus
qu'avant mathématiques qu'on trouve dans
toute notre utilisation d'outils
d'outils numériques dans tout ce qui est
mobilisation dans les domaines très
variés comme mais les sciences
naturelles comme la biologie comme la
physique comme l'économie comme la
philosophie et donc il est indispensable
d'avoir des mathématiciens beaucoup de
garçons parmi les lauréats des trois
compétitions à cette remise des prix
encore trop peu de filles dans les
mathématiques qui néanmoins aspire à se
féminiser
on peut se passer les filles à
s'orienter vers notamment limmat
les sciences finalement et je pense que
les parents comme les professeurs de la
plus poussée
dirigés vers ti matière là qui sont très
intéressante
permettent aussi nous épanouir
on fait nous mêmes une promotion on a
invité récemment des jeunes filles a
visité l'institut des hautes études
scientifiques et la consigne qui avait
été passé aux établissements s'étaient
de solliciter principalement les filles
après les olympiades académiques
prochain défi pour les lauréats
les olympiades nationales et pourquoi
pas pour les plus talentueux les
olympiades internationales culture les
nuits de l'orangerie au château de
versailles et coup d'envoi hier soir
avec un feu d'artifice autour des
oeuvres de haendel compositeur allemand
symbole de la musique baroque de la
première partie du xviiie siècle les
images sont signés patrick jacques de
dixmude
pour cette deuxième édition des nuits de
l'orangerie au château de versailles
c'est haendel avec son oeuvre baroque
qui a enchanté le public une
représentation conclue par une
intervention pyrotechnique la carothèque
oui on en fait beaucoup mais on ne fait
pas souvent un spectacle en concert live
avec de la pyrotechnie
ça nécessite à la fois un orchestre et
des artificiers muscles bien décalés les
uns avec les autres
on va dire qu'ici tous demandent
beaucoup de travail donc je crois qu'on
est dans la norme
le groupe f connu entre autres pour son
feu d'artifice à la tour eiffel lors du
passage à l'an 2000 était en charge de
ce grand final de louis xiv qui a donné
à son époque à la pyrotechnie une
ampleur jamais atteinte aurait sans
doute apprécié c'est tout à fait
intéressant c'est pesant je verrai des
morsures que je connaissais vraiment pas
du tout ça me plaît beaucoup c'est un
genre de musique que j'apprécie déjà
écouté à la maison alors là dans un
cadre comme ça ça peut pas être mieux
puis on a ce soir ciel absolument
magnifique alors donc moi je suis ravi
ce soir-là à versailles avec ce
spectacle intitulé musique pour feux
d'artifice royaux les oeuvres de lully
mouret et un corps downing heurts ont
aussi contribué à faire renaître le
faste d'antan ce sont 80 musiciens des
instruments à vent essentiellement je
suis content and elle a composé les
musiques pour les feux d'artifice faux
c'était pour être joués en plein air en
même temps qu'un feu d'artifice
donc on met pas des violon et clavecin
qui sont peu sonore on met au contraire
des aubois débats sont des trombones
décor des trompettes de la percussion
bref tout ce qui sonne en plein air la
grande écurie comme on l'appelait à
paris bien c'est tard un peu ce les
instruments à haut débit
du xviie et du xviiie siècle prochaines
dates de ces nuits de l'orangerie au
château avec un ballet roméo et juliette
chorégraphié par jean christophe maillot
et on terminera la saison d'été avec six
représentations d'un spectacle 100%
pyrotechniques par le groupe f au
nouveau le roi de feu louis xiv c'est
lui qui va entre guillemets décider des
feux d'artifice ce soir là et aboutir
bien sûr à la gloire du soleil voilà
pour cette édition du journal je vous
retrouve demain aux mêmes horaires pour
l'actualité du jour pour l'essentiel de
la semaine également résumé complet tout
de suite sur tv fil 78 file echo
présenté préparé par florane parfait
bonne soirée